H so so someone said that Jehovah's
winess wants to talk to us about
Colossians
1 15 so let's
see how you doing guys you right pretty
good are you the Jehovah's Witness I am
yeah welcome to the P Che man so I've
been like I was told to come here by
some guy called Jordan we speak to him
over the last day or I say day like a
couple weeks um but he's having
yeah he basically said I'll come speak
to you guys and you can hopefully answer
my question um it's about Colossians
1:15 I'm sure you guys what aware of our
argument of the UN the Unitarian
position
yeah obviously if Jesus is the it calls
him the first one of all
creation um and therefore by my
understanding he would be part of that
group he would be created as the first
thing in all creation um can I ask a
serious of questions before I actually
make the main point to that's what I'm
saying well you it sound like you did
make the main point he already did I
would have I have questions on that we
got lots of questions we got lots of
questions by the way are you familiar
with the Jehovah's Greek Interlinear
Bible on their website I'm not but I'm
not too fast about like obviously the
new word translation in in the and the
in Linea based on the fact like no
Bible's perfect so if there are slight
mistakes I'm not too fast about
defending them I'm more here to speak
about theology oh so so you think
there's mistakes in the New World
Translation
no I said no Bible's perfect so there's
going to be there's no doubt mistake
because we we don't know we don't have
the original copies and nobody's a
perfect translator but can I ask my
question
iead okay but hold on but I want to know
like what source is authoritative for
you so if I show you what Jehovah's with
a source on this topic sounds like
you're not going to take it seriously
it's like oh it can be a mistake so
what's an authoritative source for you
if it's not the Watchtower organization
itself well it's just I I when I do in
my studies I I look at M translations
obviously including the new word
translation but it's just multiple
translations for example even in this in
the um Jo Witness religion we don't use
just one Bible like if you were to
download our app you can download the it
includes the um King James version it
includes the Bon the ran The New
American Standard I believe so it's not
just one Bible we use there's multiple
Bibles to authoritative for you or
no authoritative authoritative in what
sense what the the translation
translation
interpretation well the what defines
your belief the Bible is what I I see as
my authority obviously the new
translation is a good translation in my
opinion so the
B say again if the Bible disagrees with
The Watchtower organization you would
side with the
Bible um yeah but obviously I don't
believe the watch organization disagrees
with the Bible but can I speak about
what I came here to speak about
can can I can I speak out why I came
here to like again I was
inv you guys canar answer questions
let's talk about Colossians 115 so 115
you're saying that he's the first born
of all creation so let's start there but
yeah cool so let me premise my my my my
main point um and that is by a simple
question who's the firstborn
human and this there not trick trick
question it doesn't matter how you
answer some people answer Adam some
people say Cain some people even say
Jesus it doesn't how you answer the
firstborn human was the is the firstborn
son of of uh Adam and Eve so Kane so why
didn't you say like an angel was a
firstborn human or a giraffe was a
firstborn human is an angel a
human perfect so you would agree that to
be the firstborn of something the
labeled firstborn of a group you have to
be part of that group no no no the
context what you're asking the question
gives us a different definition of
firstborn firstborn when how you use it
is defined by the context yep nice try
though what what do you mean how he use
it so so again the first born human it
doesn't have to be human you're
basically saying where's my question to
you now um who was the first king of
Israel firstborn king of
Israel initially it was King Su then it
was King David wait you said so it had
two
firstborns yeah initially it was King sa
he was the first born prior to King Saul
there's no there was no king of Israel
and that his and the kingship
and and then the kingship was given to
to King David but who the first born
king of Israel I just answer your
question it was King s it's like saying
who who's the first born son of Isaac oh
no you didn't answer the question I'll
ask I did I did it was Saul and then it
was King David that's the answer to your
question so was was Solomon also the
firstborn King was Solomon also the
firstborn King no he wasn't why would he
be so how does your argument make
sense well I'm I'm not making an
argument Avery asked a question I
answered it so I didn't make an argument
yeah you're making you're making an
argument you just don't understand what
you're saying so the argument that
you're making is is that whoever is the
king of Israel Whoever has the kingship
is the firstborn that's the argument
that you're actually no that's that's
not what I said if you actually listen
closely I said that
the well how about let me explain what I
just said I said the kingship of Saul
was passed to King David and that that's
the case it states first Samuel W Warden
did I ask about the the passing of the
kingship is that what I asked about no
you asked me who is who was the
firstborn king of Israel right yes that
was my question
so and I answered so that that means
both of them were so was was Esau the
firstborn son of no no just answer the
question who firstborn son King Saul and
then King David So King David was hold
up everybody
stop when you say when you say it was
King Saul
then it was David that's you say it
sounds like you're saying that both Saul
and David were the firstborn king of is
no no no I explained myself quite
clearly it was his kingship was
King the firstborn
King initially it was Saul then his
kingship was passed to David all right
thank you so much Saul was no longer no
longer the firstborn it was David wait
wait so so you're saying that now David
was also the firstborn king of
Israel he became it yes according to
Psalms 89:2 hold on a second hold hold
on a second so you have so Israel has
two
firstborn
Kings yet one in in a literal sense and
one in a figurative sense again I've
already explained myself i' I've already
explained
myself Jacob and Esau right who was who
was the literal first of Isaac it's okay
I got you so so you're saying
that firstborn can be used literally and
firstborn can be used figuratively is
that correct yeah I've got no issue with
that correct and how do you how do you
know if firstborn is being used
literally or if it's being used
figuratively based on the context based
on the context very good now that we got
this out the way let's go back to
Colossians where in the context of
Colossians tells you that Jesus is the
literal firstborn of
creation um it's implied as I expressed
before hence my question to you I said
who's the firstborn human you said only
a human can be the firstborn human right
I didn't say that I didn't say that
answer you you did say that you did say
that again so I can I can ask you the
same question hey Warden Warden your
time is going to be very let me show
just tell you how this works okay
because I I like long conversations
as long as the person is direct with me
as long as they're honest and as long as
they don't lie and as long as they don't
waste my freaking time so I'm going to
give it to you again you have the floor
what in the context of uh Colossians
115 says that firstborn is literal go
ahead so there's two ways is by the use
of it the word itself whenever somebody
in the Bible is called the first one or
something they always part the category
there's not a single example in the
Bible where somebody is the first oneor
or something and they themselves do not
belong to the category feel free to try
and find an example you won't be able to
find one the second part which is which
would suggest that Jesus is is um is
applied literally if you go to
verse
17 well if you I should read from verse
16 let me just guess up because I can
guess up in front of
me waiting for this
[Music]
do I'll actually read from verse
15 we're waiting yeah I'm guessing up
bear with
me so it says the son is the image of
the invisible God the firstborn of all
creation the next the F first word in
verse 16 is the word hottie h o TI which
means because it's a conjunction so it's
explain telling you why called the
firstborn of all okay go ahead it sent
you why so it says for all things were
created the things in heaven and the
things in Earth the things visible and
the things invisible whether they are
Thrones or dominions or rulers or
authorities all things were created
through him and for him but my point I
want to make is in verse 17 were all
things were let me finish my point if
you don't no no what did you say just
repeat that
part just repeat that one part repeat
that one part I know that to you all
things were made through him okay good
yeah so in verse 1 your corrupt your
corrupt je witness translation thanks
for so if you can just let me finish if
you don't mind again your interrup you
keep saying you keep saying that and
we're letting you finish but you're not
actually answering the
question yeah and you're not answering
the questions I am I'm trying to but
you've interrupted me so then verse 17
it says he is before all things now
obviously him being before all things is
is a temporal statement so if the if
he's been if he's before all things and
the before all things serves as a
temporal statement to explain why he's
the firstborn then the only way you can
understand the term protos the the word
firstborn is in a temporal way which
would mean that he's before all things
in a point at a point in time if you had
10 brothers and one of the brothers said
I'm the firstborn and you asked that
brother well in what sense in the sense
of preeminence or in the sense of aital
firstborn he said well I'm before with
my brothers you would always naturally
understand the before to mean before in
time so that's that's what I would say
so so let me let me ask you this let me
ask you this question pleas hold on on
yeah go ahead is is is Jehovah the first
the first what sorry is he the
first you'd have to qualify what you
mean by the first he the first and the
last is he the
first yes he is the first yes in that
sense first first what you just said in
the in the context of the first and the
last so you're referring to Revelation
22:13 I'm referring to Isaiah actually
44 which is also relation to the same
thing so what's the first he answer the
question instead of dancing around it
trying to guess what verse it is what is
I would say he's he's the first God
that's what it's in reference to first
God yeah so this is kind of switching
topics now
obviously first God that's not what it
says there says the first and the last
the first
what yeah I said God based in the
context of Isaiah I would say he's the
first and last God so so so hold on a
second did creation come after
God yes so is he before creation
yes so does that does that mean that God
is temporal because he's before
creation no it doesn't oh so just so
when it says that Jesus your arum just
went out the window when it says that
Jesus is before all things that doesn't
mean that he's temporal it means that
creation is temporal he is without time
which is why he's before all things just
like this is this is why the scripture
say before the mountains were brought
forth before all creation from
everting you are God so the term before
all creation is used specifically of
Yahweh so are you denying that before is
not a temporal statement uh it's not a
temporal statement for God it's a
temporal statement for what comes after
him yeah but in that yeah but of course
I understand what you're saying but in
this context of choss 1 15 15- 16 if
he's before it yeah he's before all
things but it's the all things that were
made through him not necessarily himself
if he is a creative being wait hold on
he's not a Crea being he's the creator
of all things exactly that's begging the
question that's beg question begging the
question that's what the text says what
you
read that's why I had you read it again
it says it says all things made through
made through him by that's why I had you
read the part
again yeah so it says all things were
made through him right but that's by God
yes all things which don't include
himself like it says specifically
it says P not all other things P all
things but all things so again like I
said all things that were made through
him he didn't make himself it says all
things it doesn't say all things that
were made through
him all things were made through
him he's the one who made all things
here here my friend do you do you know
do you know Greek
syntax elizabe not much so what is so
what is Dr so what does Dr plus the
generative
mean I wouldn't be able to answer that
so I know obviously so let me tell so
let me tell you let me tell this is a
tough panel conversation man it's a
tough panel to be a heretic for real
exactly so this this is a this is
a it's a construction meaning the
genitive of intermediacy
that Jesus is the agent of
the father created all things through
the son he is the agent of creation so
if all things were created through Jesus
then he is not something that is created
because he is the one doing the
creating if all other things were
created through Jesus then that means
you would have to put another word there
Allah or something else other things but
that's not what the text
says was made through him all was made
through
him yeah so at the end of verse 16 all
things were created through him and for
him so all things relat to the things
that were created through him and for
him like like I've been sayen the whole
time and that you have to understand
that that again I'm just reading the
text so at the end of verse 16 all
things no you're not you're adding
you're adding things so what does it say
because it says because it says hot in
Alto
Esten
tant all things in him were
made exactly and let let me just confirm
black doctor's point I know you already
threw the Watchtower organization under
the bus but in case there's any
Jehovah's Witnesses who actually take
the Watchtower seriously and don't throw
them under the bus let's read what they
say about this to confirm exactly what
black doctor said quote a literal
rendering of the group would be all
things however such a rendering could
give the impression that Jesus was not
created but was the creator himself what
that's your Jehovah's Witnesses that's
the watch organization admitting
that that's why I was checking if before
the conversation so I didn't chuck the
money of the BS I said that no no
Bible's perfect I said no Bible's
perfect are you saying this is not aible
these are their notes these are their
footnotes yeah no sorry you said I chck
them under the bus but that was in
relation to my initial comments to you
when I first joined this thing that I
said I'm not here to defend the new word
translation do you accept or reject what
your Scholars have just said so no
because there's exceptions to all things
in scriptures even when you accept or
reject what your Scholars just said a no
wasn't an answer to that question so the
fact that it it could imply that Jesus
is the
creator yes when an actual when you read
it the way that I agree with the fact it
could yeah I've got no I've got no issue
with been missing on at face value it
seems to imply it but if you would hear
me out
then recogniz what you listen so let's
recognize what you just said if we read
the text the way that Paul wrote it it
tells us that Jesus is the Creator and
therefore God right no not the Creator
so in verse 16 but based on Colossians 1
verse 15 if we
were
tant for in all things for in him all
things were made yeah so if you could
let me actually make a response a proper
response
inen in heaven and on
Earth k
visible and not visible are you guys
thron or dominions or rulers or authori
so so so I'm asking you warden so
when Paul describes the things created
by Jesus he says things in heaven things
in Earth visible invisible Thrones
dominions rulers authorities t
pant so is there
anything in all of creation because Paul
exhaust the Greece the Greek language
here in Colossians 1 is there anything
that Paul says is not created by Jesus
that came into
existence if I start giving a response
it's three on one at the moment if I
start giving a response am I going to be
interrupted or am I going to be complain
you're not going to
last listen you guys speak yeah I but
obviously I don't want
yous just
answer just answer the question just
answer question and stop crying I'm
trying to make sure I I I'm not crying
I'm say opportunity to speak that's it
it's your Flor it's your floor thank
cheers um so the all things in the in
the in the text even when the language
seems to be be exhausted it still can
have exceptions and we can see this in
other texts for example if you look at
Hebrews 2:7 8 in this text so about got
about 15 seconds there so I'm using
other texts to explain it uses the same
language so if you can let me again give
an answer rather than being interrupted
go ahead just go ahead go ahead perfect
thank you go bro um I'm trying to oh my
goodness um y this keep complain I can't
I can't de
arrogance in Hebrews 2 verse 7 oh let me
read from verse six it says but one
testified in a certain place saying what
is man that you are mindful of him or
the son of man that you take care of him
you have made him a little lower than
the Angels you have crowned him with
glory and honor and set him over the
works of your over the works of your
hands you have put all things so the
same word there we see in Colossians 1:1
16 you have put all things in subject
under his feet for in and then then it
goes on to qualify what the all things
means for in that he put all thing all
in subjection under him he left nothing
that is not subject to him so what does
the all things mean what does it
Encompass what means nothing has been
left out it includes every single thing
but we know that the Angels weren't
subject to the him God's not subject to
the him it still has natural exclusions
so in the same way when we look at the
context of choss 1:15 if it calls Jesus
the first oneor of all creation and then
goes on to explain that all things have
being made through him there can be
exceptions Jesus being that exception
even though the language seems exhaled
it doesn't necessarily mean it's the
case can I can I respond now because you
just butchered Hebrews 2
and please keep reading to to verse 8 9
and 10 because this completely varries
his whole position that's exactly what I
was about to do now honest these
Heretics are how does honest these
Heretics are just if you guys just keep
reading watch this exactly now in
putting everything in subjection to him
he left nothing outside of his control
it's exclusive but then he says at
present we do not yet see everything
subject to him but we see him who for a
little while was made lower than the
Angels namely Jesus crowned with Glory
and Honor because of the suffering of
death so that by the grace of God he may
taste death for everyone for it was
fitting that he for whom and through
whom all things exist okay wait wait
wait
wait I wonder why W skip that part I
wonder why he would skip that part so it
affirms that it was for all things were
created for Jesus and through Jesus by
means of Jesus and bringing many sons to
Glory should make the founder of their
salvation perfect through
suffer
Hebrew so you're going to Hebrews 2
actually supports us exactly so hold on
how does this negate the fact that all
things exceptions in Hebrew term the
term everything as defined by Hebrews
means that nothing is left out
everything to Jesus no no so verse 7 is
in relation to mankind is is is Hebrews
verse Hebrews 2 vers who can I respond
so you you just said you just said what
you have to say can I can I respond no
no actually I actually I didn't okay so
so here so you've got the to try to so
here
stop to
argue that Hebrews is talking about
Mankind when he literally applies it in
verse 9 to Jesus as the direct
fulfillment of this because this entire
thing is about Jesus it has been
testified somewhere then he quotes the
passage he doesn't say anything about
Humanity he says Jesus
him who for a little while was made
lower than the Angels namely
Jesus so who are we going to trust you
Warden or the author to the Hebrews who
is the author speaking about Jesus or
Humanity now you can open up your mic
and respond
man dude has been complaining the whole
time that he can't talk now doesn't want
to talk now we let you talk and you
won't say
nothing I invited you my was off I
didn't realize I didn't realize I had to
turn my mic on first time on Tik Tok um
so if you go to Hebrews 2 vers 2:6 as I
read before but there is a place where
someone has testified what is mankind
that you are mindful of them most
Scholars if you go to any most
commentaries most commentaries say this
is in regards to mankind
that's why it says we do not yet see all
things subject un him because it's
speaking about Mankind because this is
the fa what I was trying to say before
before you interrupted me was this is an
application of Psalms 8 verse5 6 and 7
and Psalms 8 ver5 6 and 7 is in relation
to Genesis 1 verse 26 which is about God
subjecting all things under Adam Adam
simply means mankind so Psalms
8:5 um 67 Genesis 1:26 are all linked
and Hebrews 2:6 and 7 are simply quoting
this so this is about Mankind like I
said hence the reason why it says we do
not yet see all things in sub to him
whereas verse 9 opens up but we see
Jesus so it's changing from the fall of
Man in relation to all things being
subed to him but then they he fell into
sin and they're no longer in subed to
him so now Jesus being the last Adam and
all things now being in subject into
Adam so my case still stands and the
fact is in Hebrews 2 2: 6 7 and 7even
all things were subjected under
mankind but that didn't include
literally every single thing it didn't
include the Angels it didn't include God
and we can see that if you go to Psalms
8:6 and 7 it it qualifies what the all
things were subjected what all things
were subjected under mankind it was the
birds it was the the animals the things
in the Genesis account not
Angels I'm going to say this one more
time I'm going to ask this one more time
who does the author to apply it to
because it says he applies it as
him that they have crowned him with
power and Glory which is the subject of
the
PSAL so who's the
he in Hebrews
2 2 Verse 6 talking
about
yeah so were two seconds so that he
relates to Adam and obviously Adam is
just a term for mankind
Rel to the eny of Hebrews 2 who does who
does the who does the Blessed Apostle
apply this Psalm
to doesn't say them it says him we read
6 Seven 8 and N so who's the
him so it depends on what translation
you read it from some translations
actually say us because it's referring
to are you going to let me answer some
translations for example the see the
contemporary well when you're when
you're being when you're being
disingenuous I don't think it would be
very hard for someone to beated
disingenuous saying that the
contemp answer is right because the
answer is right in front of your face so
again then when we ask you because we
didn't we didn't when we when we pointed
this out to you earlier you didn't say
well it depends upon the translation
you've been arguing from the same
translation this entire time and we've
been arguing from the same translation
this entire time then when I ask you
something dealing with the translation
we've been dealing with this entire time
the text you say well it depends on
translation but it because there's
multiple there's multiple reasons why
I'm not sure this guy just talking he's
applying it to now now who's
interrupting now who's interrupting I'm
trying to get in because you you won't
stop talking if I'm honest with you oh
you can just interrupt whenever you want
to you so you can hold on hold on you
can interrupt whenever you want but
whenever apparently we're the ones wrong
for interrupting you whose live do you
think this
is Mr this is my first time on Tik Tok
my first time on Tik Tok yeah you know
God logic's name is
Avery yeah because no it's the first
time I've spoken on Tik Tok and gone
live on Tik Tok but I've seen Avery
before so yeah that's I I I still don't
I still don't get that we're getting
away from the point the te the point is
clear the person that the person whom
he's applying it to is Jesus Jesus is
the subject of the psalm here according
to the author of Hebrews again but we
we're getting we're getting away from
the point period
because Colossians 1 1516 and 17 uses
the term
tapa what was that logic we got to give
him let's give him a chance to respond
cheers um again I don't think it's me
being disingenuous for saying stuff like
the cev translation and other
translations many other translations
render it as us rela to humans not just
not just Jesus even if you look at um
verse um seven or six I think it's verse
seven when it say son of man it uncap
UNC capitalizes the the sun in most
translations and the reason why I didn't
bring this up I made the point of the
ask before is because there's multiple
reasons why it can be in relation to
Simply mankind I mentioned it before
about Psalms verse 8 56 and 7 and
Genesis 1:26 there's multiple Reasons
I'm not going to shotgun them all at
once so that's the reason why I didn't
bring up before but the point is the
term us is applied in some translations
and in some other translations it says
mankind some other translations it says
humans some of them it just says man but
the point is in verse 8 it says yet at
present we do not see everything in
subjecting to them that's reading from
the NIV which applies this to mankind so
the point is if this isn't relation to
Jesus then why does it say yet at
present we do not see everything can
subjects to them but we do see things
made subject to Jesus because it's not
about Jesus in verse 7 and 8 that's
clear by the end of verse eight and the
context
ofse
question he just because he forgot what
he was arguing
exactly let but let's even but leth
still here he makes the argument that in
Hebrews chapter Hebrews chap
2:8 that it says we don't see everything
a subjection to them or to
us let's go to the let's go to let's go
to the Greek what is
Alto what's the parsing of
Alto it says I'm looking at on the Bible
Hub it says the usage is he she it they
the same no Alto Alpha
oon um Al
846a so I'm looking at the term I think
it's the the Lexical Word or the same
word that you're referring to to no
you're referring you're you're just
referring to the Greek term alas I'm
talking about the dative masculine
singular
form he basically just gave it away so
yeah I don't have that in front of me
the I'm there so it says to him from
what I can see this is just one
reference in Bible isn't always accurate
because it's it's no it's it's the Greek
designates it as a singular not as a
plural in fact when it quotes the when
it quotes the subagent version of the
song it's used anthropos not
anthropo so I've got no issue with this
being in relation to one person like I
said before I believe when I usually
speak to you literally just argued that
it wasn't and that it means multiple of
mankind if you just let me finish you
would know that that's basically what
I'm saying if you let me finish so I
usually argue that
I I usually argue that this is in
relation to Adam but Adam simply means
man it's it's a general reference to
mankind but Adam is obviously in the
single person so it's in relation to
Adam but he represents mankind that's
why to him I've got no issue with it
being to him I simply mentioned that
other translations render it saying us
or mankind or him or them that I simply
I didn't make my main argument from
there I got no issue with it raising to
one person namely Adam the person Adam
but things are no longer in subjection
to Adam because he fell but they are now
in subjection to Jesus Christ so where
does the author to the Hebrews say
anything of that sort I've made it clear
if you go to Hebrews 2:8 it says yet at
present we do not see everything in sub
to him but well that can't be the case
because all things are made subject to
Jesus but then in the very next verse in
verse in verse 9 say but we do see Jesus
who was made I'm ref I'm just simply
reading what the verse is it simply says
you just read it and said that can't be
the
case yeah in the case of so it says we
do not see everything subject to to to
him but is has everything been subject
to Jesus of course it has so the verse
can't be speaking about Jesus wait wait
just just really quick so it has been
testified somewhere what is man that
you're mindful of him or the son of man
that you care for him you made him for a
little while Lord and the angels you're
saying that that's about Adam if you
keep reading into the next verse that
makes it very clear
yes you have crowned him with Glory and
Honor putting everything in subjection
under him under his feet finish it not
finish
it wait is that about Adam or not no so
read read verse eight I
am so far so but so yeah this is about M
Adam yeah now putting everything in
subjection to him he left nothing
outside of his control at present we do
not yet see everything in subjection to
him to Adam still same brother that's
yeah that that's that's that's exactly
yet we do not see things in subje to
Adam because he fell but it
say it says that eventually you will see
everything in subjection to Adam sorry
what translation you reading from this
ESV man it's the same thing in the Greek
same thing same thing in the so I'm I'm
looking at the ESV right now and it says
at present we do not see everything in
subje to him yeah so yeah we don't see
things in sub yeah at present we don't
see sub so according to you this is
talking about Adam and soon we will so
not so everything right now is under
subjection to Adam but we don't yet see
it and soon we will see how everything
is subject to
Adam it says he left nothing that was
not subject to him this is a reference
to Genesis 1 ver 26 where it
say I'm gonna ask again go for
it verse eight is about Adam is that
correct that's correct so everything is
under subjection to
Adam that's
correct but it says that but for now we
don't yet see everything in subjection
to him but we will see it soon the
future no it doesn't say we will see it
in the future it doesn't say that well
it says yes yes it says the the the
Greek phrase is noon day which means not
yet and implies a future
recognization so I'm looking at the same
thing on like I'm looking at the nas um
concordance it says now the present just
now now present the present case so
saying at this time right now just now
even now just at it says at present we
do not yet see everything in subjection
to him implying that in the future we
will see everything in subjection to him
that's that's that's reading from one
particular translation from the ESV for
example it's what the Greek says do you
want to see what what theek hold on hold
on so I could read from another
translation say this is what the Greek
says all translations are based in the
Greek so everything is what the Greek
says there's different ways according to
the Greek at present that that's what it
says we do not yet yet correct we do not
yet see
right yeah but then what does it say in
the so if it's something that's not yet
that implies a future right not if you
read the context of the next
verse thanks for
coming I just want to emphasize another
point if you keep reading to verse 10
for it was fitting for him for whom
through things and through whom all
things all things exist there you go
but we we spend all our time ignoring
that part you guys read verse n so
nothing in in is uh now in putting
everything in subjection to him he left
nothing out of his control at present we
do not yet see everything in subjection
to him verse 9 but we see him who for a
little while was made lower than the
angel who he said was Adam earlier it
continues namely
Jesus crowned with Glory and Honor
because of the suffering of death so
that by Grace by the grace of God he
might taste death for everyone for it
was fitting that he for whom and by whom
all things exist and bringing many sons
to Glory should make the founder of
their salvation perfect through
suffering what a waste of time a b we we
pointed this out we pointed this out
earlier but he spent most of his time
trying to point it out that it's not
Jesus this is why I was pressing him on
it and he kept crying that I interrupted
him because he went away from the point
and didn't answer the question directly